duck breasts never be scared about
cooking this bird absolutely delicious
very healthy first oven on 200 degrees
and then
salt pepper
now the salt will help to extract the
water out of the fat nonstick pan no oil
but start the duck breasts in the pan
cold
skin side down it feels
and sounds a little bit weird but if you
put them into a cold pan and turn the
heat up gradually it starts to release
the fat
if we put them into a hot pan
it seals them in and the fat stays in
there we want to render that fat down
90 of that duck breast will be cooked on
its skin
keeps the duck nice and moist but more
importantly it stays crispy
[Music]
once the fat comes out turn the duck
over
nice high hot heat
seal the duck
now they're going in the oven skin side
down 200
six to eight minutes
if your pan's got a plastic handle on it
then transfer the duct brush onto a tray
but make sure you put the tray into the
oven to get hot first
cooking duck is like cooking a piece of
beef and you can't slice it piping hot
all the goodness runs out
just quickly turn it over
push your fingers in there and it's
slightly
resistant but still quite bouncy and
that confirms they're quite pink in the
center but the important part now is
leaving that to rest let them cool down
and then we'll slice them
keep that excess duck fat
and there you go next time you're
sauteing potatoes you just take them to
a completely different level now slicing
the dirt just slice it at an angle not
too thin if you slice it thinly it goes
cold quickly so nice thick slices
nice crispy skin on top
and a beautiful clump
roasted duck
all the white fat gone nice crispy skin
absolutely delicious
[Music]
nice long strokes so we get the whole of
the blade
three fingers
one in front two behind and this part of
the knuckle